[Music]
from the director of Harry Potter back
when that meant something and a massive
child star who turned out pretty normal
by child star standards and since we are
the 30th anniversary of the rare holiday
sequel that isn't terrible
unnecessary I just forgot all about
Christmas or completely off the rails
hold tightly to my belt for we are going
to journey through the air and circle
the world
Home Alone 2 lost in New York
[Music]
it's Christmas time once again for the
McAlister's Buzz is still a bully beat
Daniel trout sniffer Fuller is a whiz
kid you sleep on the third floor yeah me
mom's telepathic I have that feeling
and the other 12 are background gingers
who contribute nothing at all to the
story but while big p doesn't even get a
line laugh along with little Kevin while
he talks to himself for two hours
my family's in Florida and I'm in New
York last Hotel New York 's most
exciting Hotel Express
ion Merry Christmas kids this is the
greatest action can mess with a lot of
things you can't mess with kids like hey
Uncle Rob lives here they're back from
Paris I'll drop in on them there's
nobody else in the room Kev Uncle Frank
really messed you up huh you know what
they're going to call you in France
don't you huh no yank
thank you
when Kevin gets shunned by his own
family again and stuck up in the Atticus
punishment again he'll be all alone
thanks to a last second travel mix up
again lies to adults again you think I'd
be here alone I don't think so a kid
going into a hotel making a reservation
I don't think so make use of convenient
movie dialogue again I'm gonna give you
to the count of ten I'm gonna give you
to the count of three get stopped by two
burglars again build up a library trap
house again get build a muscarial
stranger again
hey come on it all worked out great the
first time why don't I just try it again
just don't try it again again Home Alone
3 or again again Home Alone taking back
the house again again again again Home
Alone the Holiday Heights and definitely
not again again again again that would
just be stupid home sweet home alone
revisit screenwriter John Hughes happy
plays the white side of Chicago then
take advantage of 1992's lacks airport
security are you sure your family's on
this flight yeah to visit New York City
scale the mighty Twin Towers experience
the magic of Central Park watch it kid
and potentially get shot on Fifth Avenue
down the hall and to the left just don't
cross the staff of The Plaza Hotel these
grinches are out to ruin Christmas by
refusing to let a child fake his
identity
his father commit fraud
you got it
and step them on tips and there's plenty
more where that came from sucky
grown-ups doing your jobs hope you get
smacked in the face and think you're
being shot to death
return to the franchise that mixes
luxurious escapism for kids with
torturing criminals to death also for
kids
Harry and Marv returned with a new
sticky gimmick where the sticky Bandits
and while the cursing remains PG
the violence is rated X as in Kevin
murders them 10 different ways
foreign
[Music]
stop
[Music]
please they're already dead
do you guys give up have you had enough
pain yes Mercy
oh
so cuddle up for a sequel to the film
about standing your ground hello that's
now about leaving your home to dish out
vigilante justice across state lines
in this celebration of every child's
most deeply held Christmas fantasies
having a talk boy eating pizza and a
limousine on your way to a toy store and
telling Rob Schneider to [ __ ] off nice
family
story
terrorist viewers week off oh so I'm
funny now huh what's the funny about me
huh oh it's all getting hit the head and
falling over stuff yeah right that's
pretty funny Happy Hanukkah Marv oi we
need to talk about
succession
Pennywise pound foolish
the Schneider cut bird woman or the
unexpected virtue of homelessness and
Jeffrey it's your friend Donald you know
those kids are looking for get all out
of this
Home Alone 2 Muppet Takes Manhattan
all right everyone let's dig in
they finally dragged down their son and
he immediately sneaks off on his own to
see the pigeon lady
will someone put a leash on this kid
you fight like a girl who is also a baby
it's me hi I'm the problem it's me
maybe it was an iguana
we put our faith in blessed heart cheese